newse voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track where your news
is coming from news voice helps you
track what corporate interests might be
influencing the narratives in the news
you read every day arm yourself against
corporate media monopolies by
downloading the news voice app for free
using the link right underneath this
video okay so yesterday Donald Trump had
a had a rally indoors at a mega church
in Arizona
you might be wondering wait a second
Eric let me check my notes Arizona
Arizona is one of the worst-case growth
coronavirus hot spots in the world never
mind the country does that is that the
right place to have a big indoor rally
and you would be right to ask that
question Arizona is the state indeed
with the largest percentage case
increase in the last week or so cases of
forty eight percent in the last eight
days in Arizona case is just spiking
hugely so what does the president do he
holds a rally indoors at a huge Church
in Arizona now before we even go further
people have been emailing me saying how
can a church hold a campaign event
churches are given nonprofit tax-exempt
status in exchange for not doing
politics churches aren't allowed to do
politics and here they are hosting a
Trump campaign event and I agree I don't
know what to tell you I mean these what
we do know is that the rules against
churches doing politics are rarely
enforced it is very rare that a church
will actually be punished for doing
politics despite churches doing politics
being banned so I just don't have an
answer it's just we have no
accountability now faced with questions
about the the prudence prudency prudence
I'm not sure based on the questions
about the wisdom of doing this rally in
Arizona given that cases are exploding
in Arizona the CFO of Dream City Church
this was held at Dream City Church and
Dream City Church has a CFO named
Brendan
astral they posted a video saying we've
installed a new air filtration system by
the way manufactured by one of our
congregants
and it kills 99.9% of coronavirus now
health experts and anybody with common
sense immediately said that's not true
that's an absurd claim to make Arizona
State University scientists said it's an
absurd claim to make quote Matthew
scotch warned quote this is absurd and
will not protect you but here's the
church saying that this is the situation
they've got a great air filtration
system that will kill coronavirus take a
look covertly T here at Green City
Church were called the first church in
the nation - yeah we've we've installed
clean air exp we have a local Arizona
company was technology developed by some
members of our church and we've
installed these units and it kills 99.9%
of kovat within 10 minutes they have
been in testing it's not as a shoe - I
see
it's a ionization of of the air and it
takes particulate sout and Kovac cannot
live in that environment so when you
come into our auditorium 99% of Colgate
is gone you know if it was there in the
first place so you can know when you
come here you'll be safe and protected
thank God for great technology and thank
God for being proactive amen bless you
guys I like how it's not ionization it's
ionisation ionisation but it's all bs
pronounce it however you want it's
obvious now even if it were true that
their eye on is eyshan system kills the
virus in some abstract way if I'm
standing right next to somebody and they
don't have a mask and I don't have a
mask an air filtration system in the
ceiling or in the walls is not actually
going to protect me from the people that
are right next to me without masks so
it's wildly irresponsible it's absurd
and then there's the the rally itself
which was a complete and total farcical
gong show Trump was visibly sweaty and
disheveled the entire time slurring
badly
brought students up to speak during the
event who were used as pathetic and
horrible political props everything
about it was horrible Trump again going
with this racist kung-fu name for
coronavirus firing up the crowd with it
imagine cheering for this take a look
with co vid debe notice we said the
other night did anybody see my speech
the other night on Saturday then what I
said the other night there's never been
anything where they have so many names I
could give you 19 or 20 names for that
fret to get all different names Wuhan
kau Hans was catching on coronavirus
right cun flu
[Applause]
imagine 10 years from now thinking back
and saying hey remember when we went to
that rally and Trump said come flu
wasn't that great I mean the place just
absolutely loved it and that's actually
I think that you know the focus really
should be on the number of people that
love this racist come flu stuff there's
a lot of focus understandably on the
fact that the president is calling it
come flu and there should be focus on
that because we shouldn't have a
pleasant president who does that there's
no question about it but the audience
was filled with people who loved it
that's the problem though the Trump
saying it is a problem but if that
immediately repelled people from voting
for him we would say okay this is a
madman racist but nobody's voting for
him the crowd loved it the audience if
you listen to that clip the audience was
actually shouting out come flu Trump
started saying wuhan virus Chinese virus
the crowd is yelling Kong flu they want
him to say it they're delighted by the
racism of it all and I think that we
want to distribute criticism fairly and
Trump saying this would not be nearly
the problem that it is were it not for
the fact that huge crowds of people
absolutely love it now here's Donald
Trump in the same rally yesterday a
railing against vote-by-mail saying
listen we voted in World War one and we
voted during World War two
absentee ballots are fine absentee
ballots are fine like I live in the
White House and if I can't get to
Florida or you live wherever you live
you can't but you have to go through a
process some people just can't make it
to a polling station and they have good
reason but they have to go through this
process in order to verify their
identity people went to the polls and
voted during World War one they went to
the polls and voted during World War two
we can safely go to the polls and vote
during kovat night
now what's funny about this or scary is
that vote by mail is absentee ballots
like what were Trump seems not to get it
but what we're talking about is getting
everybody an absentee ballot it's just
more of them Trump seems to imagine that
if it's vote by mail it's different than
the absentee ballots that he used and
that he says they're okay and then Trump
raises this issue about we voted during
World War one in World War two the wars
weren't contagious pandemics and
soldiers during those wars did vote by
mail so it's it's like a completely
irrelevant claim that Donald Trump is
making Trump also as is very common now
during these rallies particularly ones
that are happening later in the day
Trump having trouble speaking here he is
talking about America's founders it's
the same spirit that drove America's
grounders and then here's Donald Trump
unable to say deployed he says deplore
instead and that's why when rioting and
looting broke out in our nation's
capital I quickly deplore I came in I
deployed the National Guard very quickly
so it was a truly a responsible mess but
the good news like if there's anything
even slightly reassuring about what
we're seeing is that Trump's polling is
suffering very very badly because of his
handling of coronavirus Trump is an
incumbent president four months out from
his reelection kimball reelection and
most national polls have been polling in
the 30s okay that's a good sign in the
sense that he can't he's not as Teflon
as he was once believed to be on race
relations on coronavirus that new New
York Times poll we talked about earlier
he's suffering badly so even though he
was able to fill a room with people
cheering for kung fu he is suffering in
the polls we just have to see whether it
holds through to November and that's why
I was very cautious earlier today when
talking about polling the good news is
maybe maybe he can't actually get away
with this stuff